hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll when
I wrote my book something deeply hidden
which was about quantum mechanics in the
introduction I started off by pointing
out that quantum mechanics is a
fascinating physical Theory also
incredibly relevant both to the
foundations of physics as currently
practiced and to technology and
basically the way we understand the
world but it was also the subject of
some pretty dramatic public
misconceptions and one of the things I
did was go to Amazon type the word
Quantum into the search bar and see all
these Preposterous titles that purported
to be about quantum mechanics but really
weren't so imagine my delight when I
picked up a book from today's guest
David Stewart David is a very
accomplished archaeologist a specialist
in Mayan civilization and language David
was actually the youngest ever recipient
of a MacArthur Fellowship the genius
fellowships so he knows what he's
talking about and he wrote a book about
Mayan language but also cosmology and
numerology and Mathematics and Science
and so forth called the order of days
and I think it was published around 2009
so you can guess where this is going in
the introduction he says Mayan
archeology is really interesting
fascinating and yet there is this set of
public statements about the year 2012
where the Mayan calendar flips over it's
nothing more or different than going
from the year 1999 to the year 2000
right or maybe even better going from
the year 999 to 1000 where you just flip
over the odometer a little bit but
there's a whole industry of books
pretending that this was really a
prediction that the Mayans were saying
the world was going to end in December
2012 and they never said anything like
that it wouldn't have been true even if
they had said that so David had to write
a whole book explain meaning why and in
the intro to his book he complains about
all of these different books that you
can find on Amazon about exactly this
thing so we have something in common
there uh interest in important
scientific theories that can be misused
for popular well not really even popular
purposes but complete charlatan purposes
is basically what we're getting at here
so in the conversation we're going to be
talking about who the Maya were how we
know how we know how to read their
language which is actually quite a
considerable amount and how they did
Count they had a very strange counting
system you'll hear all about it how they
were led to what is called The Long
Count which is a way of having a
calendar that keeps track of certain
numbers of years and in fact they
extended this calendar to literally
something like 10 to the 28 years
effectively so that's a very long time
even by modern cosmology standards and
we're still learning a lot you know
other kinds of science like lidar are
being very useful for finding new sites
for my uh ruins in Central America
Mexico and so forth so it's a situation
where we've learned a lot in the last
few decades we're going to learn a lot
more to come that's the kind of thing
we'd like to talk about here on
mindscape so let's go
[Music]
thank you
David Stewart welcome to the mindscape
podcast well thanks for having me this
is a departure I I think that most of
the episodes that I have on mindscape
are departure in some sense from the
other episodes which is which is how I
like it but uh we rarely do history and
this is this is a wonderful mixture of
History and Science and things like that
but let's start right at the ground
floor uh remind us let's put it that way
of who the Maya were what their
civilization was where they fit into the
history of the Americas
well certainly uh the Maya are are
pretty well known as one of the uh
civilizations of the ancient Americas
um the Maya are still around that's one
thing I'd like to emphasize uh from the
get-go is that there are about four or
five million speakers of Mayan languages
uh today in Mexico Guatemala
um and the ancient culture uh goes back
quite a ways
um we can track the earliest evidence of
of Maya peoples
um really to about uh say 1500 BC or BCE
um and probably even before that
um and uh very rapidly the the Maya
really transformed from a
pre-agricultural society into a
sedentary culture and they're and then
very quickly within centuries really
they were building monuments in in even
cities I mean it's it's a tremendous uh
cultural transformation that they went
through uh so we have
um literally thousands of archaeological
sites of Maya civilization many people
have probably visited some of these
places uh some are very touristy right
now in Mexico and in Belize uh places
like Chichen Itza or or uh you know uh
Palenque in in Mexico or Tikal in
Guatemala these are some of the biggest
Ancient Maya sites um
uh in fact Tikal I have to say was
filmed in the original Star Wars movie
right as the uh the rebel moon base you
know the jungle site with the Towering
pyramids that's that's the Maya ruins of
Tikal was that was that sorry was that
The Empire Strikes Back is that or the
that was the first Star Wars film the
very first one yeah okay yeah it's
called Star Wars yeah I remember seeing
it and and going that's to call you know
when it was when it came out uh anyway
uh a little digression there but uh yeah
so so Maya civilization is a a complex
uh uh uh phenomenon in the sense that it
was many many cities that were uh
connected to each other it was never
centralized as an Empire okay uh or
something like that so uh we have a lot
of city-states so the the the time that
we know the best for the ancient Maya is
what we call the classic period right in
this run from about 200 A.D
to about 900 A.D so so many centuries
and this is when we have you know the
sites I was just mentioning uh and many
many others uh cities states Kings uh
the the thing that I work on uh in Maya
archeology my own specialty is uh the
decipherment of hieroglyphs right and so
they had a writing system they had uh
official records uh that uh have
survived in stone inscriptions uh and we
have four ancient books also that were
uh kind of science astrology manuals
very precious documents you know imagine
having these things you have to imagine
this is the tropics right so uh
you know egyptologists have it you know
they're all very lucky right because
they have this dry environment where
they have all these documents and
everything we don't have that so we have
these four precious books uh also that
we've studied
the larger Point here is that it was a
literate civilization yeah
um fantastic art fantastic
um uh architecture and uh you know we
can access
the Maya unlike any other pre-columbian
civilization right because we have their
own words going back centuries and
centuries before Columbus and if the
classic period is 200 to 900
but the Maya as a people some of them
are still around or at least you know
they've been around for a long time
um what happened in 900 like you know
did was it an organic thing or were they
uh in conflict with their neighbors
right so these are great questions in in
archeology today for those of us who are
studying the Maya around 900 uh we have
a widespread phenomenon where many of
the Cities not all of them but many of
them were abandoned we call this the
Maya collapse and uh it's no doubt a
very simplistic
kind of one-off description for a very
complex phenomenon uh and we're still
trying to understand it
um most ancient civilizations went
through these kinds of changes you know
whether you're looking at the ancient
Mediterranean ancient Egypt right we
have these ups and downs uh and there
were there was a lot going on before 200
A.D before the classic period there were
cities we call that the pre-classic yeah
and after 900 you call that the
post-classic right so there were there
were Bible around they were doing
different things uh but but that classic
period is when we have those uh you know
most of the written sources right and
and so forth so we know more about that
now what happened
um my own take on it uh and you talk to
any Maya archaeologists they probably
have different uh uh ways of of talking
about this my take on it is that
um there was a well we have really good
evidence of Rapid population growth okay
um uh kind of stunning uh trajectories
of population
uh say from six seven hundred to nine
hundred
um that must have put a strain on the
existing resources on the existing
infrastructures they had
um a lot of people nowadays are looking
at climate change and it's connection to
this right I don't think that's a causal
Factor but I think it may have
um
been something that um you know it was
part of a mix of different factors right
that that you know a few years of
drought could put real stress on these
resources again that that people were uh
competing for
um but what we're really looking at
around 900 is a uh a collapse of a
particular political system a system of
kingship and and those institutions
fizzled
um for whatever reasons and people left
many of these cities and went on to
other other places so you go to a site
like Chichen Itza today in in Yucatan in
Northern Yucatan it's it's a
grandiose Maya ruin Maya City it's
post-classic or it's right at the end of
the classic period you know and it's
representing kind of a new flavor of of
Maya civilization that emerges for a few
hundred years and then it too transforms
right so I'm really interested in seeing
how these uh the these episodes when
Maya civilization kind of remade itself
in different ways I guess one maybe
overly simplistic question is how do we
balance these external or ecological
factors of climate change or over
farming or whatever versus purely human
factors like there was a revolution or
you know they they just CR they had a
social system that couldn't be sustained
for too long is there even any way of
deciding between these possibilities
well that's a great question it's it's
hard to uh differentiate these things
um and you know a lot of research is
going into these external factors right
now
um I think there's a bit of well there's
obviously a connection there to our own
interests in climate and how it affects
people on the ground and how it affects
demography and how it affects you know
what happens in history
um
now the human factor is always going to
be key I think in all of this
um and you know one of the things I
didn't mention a few minutes ago is that
you know if we if we read the the
histories that they're writing about
themselves
starting around
700 650 A.D we just see this incredible
growth in records of War
these city-states were fighting each
other and these these dynasties were
even though they were related to each
other you know we're talking about
interrelated royal families they're
they're going after each other all the
time and we just see again this
trajectory along with the population of
conflict and so that to me is the most
important human factor here
um now what's causing that you know
population again maybe climate change
all of these things are interrelated
it's so hard for me at least to put one
factor in front of another as a primary
cause I think they're all
crystallizing together into this
um sort of bad mix of of things that's
that's happening over a couple of
hundred years it's hard to resist
drawing sweeping conclusions from this
because we tend to think that our own
civilization right here right now is
having its issues but still things are
growing the economy is getting bigger
science is advancing but historically
civilizations come and go all the time
you know there's plenty of collapses
around the world so there is a
cautionary tale Maybe
uh certainly and again we're on the
inside of our own situation we're not
going to necessarily see it the way
people do in a thousand years uh and you
know one factor here that I I think
about is that you know if we were able
to walk around a Maya capital a city
state uh say before the collapse around
say 750 A.D we would have probably seen
an incredibly vibrant
um very healthy looking uh City uh the
art was extraordinary right the the the
the presentation of culture you know the
high Arts uh the the the yes there was
you know population was growing but
there were markets everywhere
um we know this right we know that there
were lots of people living sometimes I
think quite comfortably in in some of
these spots uh maybe a hundred years or
so before what we the collapse as we
know yeah I I ponder that sometimes
right because I don't think they
necessarily saw it coming maybe they did
but but who knows it's very hard and to
give the Maya their props if I
understand correctly from my very
superficial Wikipedia reading uh even
though there was some collapse in your
post-classical Etc they were like you
say still around when the Spanish came
over and in fact it seems that they held
out longer than the Aztecs or the Inca
did against the Spanish Conquest
well that's true the uh there was no
really single conquest of the Maya
um you know we when we think about
Cortez right and in the conquest of the
Aztecs that was really the conquest of
of the capital uh what's now Mexico City
and and that that took a couple of years
but when we look at the Maya area
it took decades and decades for the
Spanish to exert control over big areas
of what's now the Yucatan Peninsula in
Guatemala and in fact until maybe a
hundred years ago there were still areas
even less than that there were still
areas that were with independent Maya
communities right so so it there's no
single episode of Conquest it's this
protracted thing one amazing
um
a kind of historical fact here that that
nobody thinks about the last Maya
Kingdom to be conquered was in 1697.
okay 200 years after Cortez you know and
and that was in northern Guatemala and
and and you know this was there was
still independent money after that right
right
um so uh well I think we're living in a
in the world that uh in that part of of
mesoamerica right where
um you know this is still a very raw
history in some respects uh it's only a
few hundred years or less and which is a
drop in the bucket in terms of History
you mentioned the uh the vibrant social
scene and the Arts what about the
technology and science like what what
kind of technological civilization are
we talking about here well we're talking
about
um a
they didn't have metal which is really
interesting when you think about it they
didn't have uh iron or bronze or steel
okay uh there was metal jewelry late in
my history gold and silver but there was
no technology of metal working
um that was used in tools and so forth
they were essentially what we would call
A Stone Age Technology now that has all
of these meanings in our own culture
yeah but but this is a high civilization
uh where they are building massive
structures
uh and uh you know monuments and and
cities
with stone tools right so uh I don't
want to say Stone Age meaning that they
were in some way primitive right I think
we have to reconcile these definitions
we have from the old world they weren't
living in caves
was that they were not living in caves
they were not living in caves they were
uh making uh amazing things out of the
technology that they had and and in its
own way it was a remarkable technology
there uh and also the this idea of
technology and science
um
you know we group those together in in
some ways but
there are scientific awareness of the
world around them was extraordinary
um we see this mostly through astronomy
we see this through the records we have
of uh you know the calendars that they
kept the observations they made of of
the heavens and of you know Horizon
based astronomy
um they they
knew what was going on in the cosmos
um in a way that many ancient
civilizations did right uh we just
happen to have the records uh that the
Maya were keeping over the long term of
these things is it even a sensible
question to ask did they think that the
Earth was the center of the solar system
or the Sun or did they talk about those
questions
well they didn't have a sense of a solar
system okay they recognized the
observable planets of course and they
differentiated those from the stars in
the background
um we know this because we have the
astronomical tables yeah this is amazing
we have tables uh of uh Venus and Mars
for example in some of the documents
where they they know the Cycles now they
recognize them much like the Greeks and
the Romans right as as these moving
stars right and they they ascribe them
maybe some uh kind of animate qualities
as deities or as as Gods
um but but they have it down right they
they know what's going on in terms of
their movements and their Cycles
um so they see the Earth as
the center of everything right their
concept of what Earth is is just the
surface on which everything happens and
they're observing the heavens above them
and all of the action that's happening
there
um they they frame their cosmology
around
uh these observations of the Sun and of
the planets
um these regular cycles and they create
an elegant understanding of these things
um that that I like to call indigenous
science
um it's in no way primitive it's it's
exactly what really all humans have been
doing
um looking at the sky over thousands and
thousands of years astronomy is always
the first science to become precise and
quantitative among ancient societies
it's really quite amazing and Universal
but and I we have a lot to say about
calendars and Science and astrology but
I do want to finish up with the
archeology here you mentioned the number
of sites some of them are touristy and
so forth are we do we know all the sites
are we done or is there a ongoing
discovery of new Maya uh
relics
oh we are in no way done uh just last
week there was the announcement of a
discovery of a new Maya site all right
in the forests of southern Mexico
um so uh this is an amazing time to be
studying
uh Maya archeology uh for many reasons
but one of them right now is the use of
lidar Technology
um lidar in the last 15 years has really
revolutionized our understanding of of
what's on the ground
um now you have to understand you know
and I know this all too well from all of
my time in doing field work
um it's really hard to
um
see a Maya ruin in the jungle
in terms of all that's there the
buildings the Mounds the features
Terraces you know you can walk through
the rainforest in northern Guatemala and
and you can see maybe some big piles of
rocks and those were ancient pyramids
sometimes you'll see walls but you can
easily walk over stuff you know and not
even know what it is roads for example
causeways now lidar which is uh and and
I'm not an expert in lidar technology
some listeners probably know much more
about it than I do but but you know it
it's this ability to use lasers to
penetrate the forest canopy to
essentially scan the forest floor
and to see all of the relief that's
there it's all it's almost like you're
shaving off all of the the forest and
seeing the terrain
I mean my God what you see is incredible
you see uh the sights we thought we knew
that you know people spent months
mapping on the ground turned out to be
two or three times the size uh and and
they just keep going
um
and also completely new sites uh that we
didn't know about uh just in the past
few years so a colleague of mine just
announced last week as I mentioned uh a
very large brand new site in in southern
Mexico called okomton
uh that he's named it and uh you know it
looks pretty special looks really uh
pretty large so we're still even today
finding
um literally Lost Cities you know
there's no other way to put it out there
in in the forest that's amazing and it
reminds me that I should take this
opportunity because I was recently asked
on an ask me anything episode uh of the
podcast is it even conceivable that
there could have been anywhere in the
world a highly technologically advanced
ancient civilization that we just have
no idea that they're there because we've
lost all of their relics or does is
archeology worldwide advance to the
point where we would know if there was
you know a computer terminal hidden
somewhere under the Rock
right right well I'm I'm in the camp uh
very very squarely uh with archeology
knowing the general parameters of these
things and and we would know if there
was a whole civilization waiting to be
discovered uh there's quite a bit of
what we call pseudo-archeology out there
um uh about very very ancient
civilizations
uh that are so old that we don't see
them right uh and uh I have to say the
evidence that's brought in to to argue
this point is just not up to Snuff
um I'm glad yeah so so it a lot of it's
wishful thinking a lot of it's tied into
kind of crazy ideas about Atlantis and
yeah and they're all these rabbit holes
involved with that but but real
archeology
um you know we know the general uh uh
timelines uh around the world they're
always new discoveries right there are
always things that push things further
back in time that's to be expected uh
we're doing that in the Maya world all
the time we're finding new things that
are older and older but
um no new civilizations I think are
going to be out there
um you know archeology is always full of
surprises but I I have to say you know
it's come a long way
over the years and we know a lot about
the ancient world well thank you for
indulging me with that now we get to
roll up our sleeves a little bit and uh
go into what has been your specialty
which is the decipherment of the writing
system that the Mayans have I mean well
I guess let's get a common basis to talk
about this what is the writing that we
have you mentioned a few books is that
is that where we get most of our
knowledge of of how Mayans would write
we have a few books uh that have
miraculously uh survived
um
the Spanish were were quite uh good at
wiping out archives that they came
across in 16th century
um and uh the few that we have were
saved uh by uh as Curiosities at the
time I think in kicking back to Europe
one was found apparently in a cave in
Mexico and uh surfaced about 50 years
ago
um
we have a lot more than just the books
we have uh thousands of texts uh on
Stone monuments
um that sometimes are sitting out in the
open sometimes they're inside of temples
you know these of course are official
kind of ritual text or histories about
dynasties uh we have well you know
what's interesting is the Maya wrote on
everything you know they wrote on they
wrote on their dishware you know they
wrote uh on uh the walls of buildings uh
graffiti
um they wrote on their uh
Jade necklaces you know uh and so we
have a lot of raw material to work with
um and
you know it it it's as I was saying
earlier it's the it's amazing to have
the words of uh ancient Americans uh to
read you know it's it's just a stunning
thing
um I sometimes have to step back and
realize that you know you know I'm
reading something that was written in
the year 600 yeah uh about Royal history
you know uh and and this is a history
we're still
um sifting through and uh it hasn't
quite reached the public Consciousness
the way I think it will I'm writing a
book now on my history that I hope will
oh good um you know get out some of this
amazing uh these amazing narratives I
want to pause for just a second to give
us a little bit of uh indulge in some
righteous indignation about the fact
that the Spanish intentionally tried to
wipe out all of these records so this is
again something you see throughout
history when one culture encounters
another one it's just a terrible human
impulse like there's not as enough of us
of an Impulse inside us to just say yes
these people are different than us but
it's worth preserving we want to wipe it
out this is just weird
yeah and you know it it it's hard to
read some of the accounts
um that are there of uh of Spanish
Friars who were uh very proactive in
um you know burning the books literally
now I I want to balance that by saying
that there were many of these same
individuals
um uh Spanish intellectuals of the time
who who were maybe Franciscan priests
who
spoke fluent Maya who were converting
the Indians as they call them converting
the Maya to Christianity but but you
also see some respect there you see that
they're really interested in
um this native culture they they want to
know more about the science of the Maya
they want to know more about
um the ruins that they saw right even in
the 1500s there were plenty of ancient
Maya ruins lying about they wanted to
know the history they wanted to know
okay what's going on here who are these
people what are what is the writing even
though some of them burned it right some
of them actually learned to read and
write in the ancient script
um people are very complicated people
are very complicated right so you see
this tension in in the documents of that
era right where they're writing down all
of this stuff thank goodness right
because they were like the
anthropologists of that time they were
providing again a lot of raw material
for us to study and dictionaries for
example of the languages
um which are really key for us in the
decipherment
um and uh you know so I have kind of a
love-hate relationship with with the uh
uh these early chroniclers uh who who
were
trying to preserve some things but also
we're very active in destroying so what
is the kind of writing system they would
use not like a symbolic alphabet like we
have more like hieroglyphics
right so we call them hieroglyphs or
glyphs that's that's a term we've
borrowed from Egypt uh no connection uh
historically in any way the aliens
didn't spread the word back and forth no
no uh it's a word to label we've just uh
transferred over uh so it is a beautiful
script
um it is uh highly ornate uh and and uh
I think to someone who has never seen a
Maya uh text before everyone looks at it
it looks just like a sea of of squiggles
you know and you see some pictures of
things so it's a pictorial system in
that
let's say the graphic units of the
script are things of daily life or maybe
images of you know you see body you see
Hands you see faces you see uh
unrecognizable elements too
um but it's not a symbolic system
um what we've discovered in the last
50 years is that it is a phonetic
writing system okay everything is
related to either a word or to a sound
and so when we're reading an ancient
text we're reading it in its original
language
we're not ascribing it some sort of
General interpretation uh you know early
Scholars were kind of doing this you
know saying okay well this is the sort
of the sense of this no we have to read
it in its original language yeah
um and so uh you know one of the hats I
wear uh is a epigrapher that is someone
who studies ancient texts is uh being a
linguist
um when I first got interested in my
hieroglyphs
at a very young age my mom and dad
dragged me into this because they were
archaeologists I was just Enchanted by
the look of Maya glyphs they were
phenomenal looking but in the early 70s
no one could read them really
and uh
you know I didn't think in order to
really play and understand with this
writing system that I would ever have to
really be a linguist right so it turned
out you know as as we made progress in
in cracking the code uh you know I had
to sit there and start learning you know
my grammar and morphology and all of
these you know phonetics and all of this
stuff
um in a way I never anticipated in a way
no one probably anticipated in back in
the old days but the point is we can now
read probably I would say about 80 to 90
percent of it in its original language
does the fact that there are still
people speaking languages that descended
from Mayan ancient languages help at all
can you you know ask them for some clues
about pronunciation it absolutely helps
um
the uh language well a couple of things
the the language of most of the ancient
texts we have it turns out is one
language
uh that's that's good for us because we
don't have to try to learn a bunch of
different ancient Mayan languages
uh what it seems is going on in the
classic period is that there's kind of a
an official courtly language okay a
lingua Franca if you will uh where
they're writing their official texts in
a particular uh language we call Classic
Mayan right and uh it was it was
probably
a somewhat archaic formal language in
its own day it wouldn't have been spoken
by uh people out in the fields or you
know even maybe in the Royal courts but
it was the official language
of documents kind of like Latin in the
Middle Ages something like that
now we can relate that language to
current Mayan languages
uh there are a lot of Mayan languages
this is something I didn't really say
earlier but uh you know we can identify
of 30 or so Mayan languages
only some of those are really related
closely to to the hieroglyphic writing
okay but those descendant languages are
still being spoken uh in in different
parts of Mexico Honduras and Guatemala
so
um absolutely you know if we can
document more about those languages some
of which are dying off I have to say
um boy does that help you know just
getting a
sense of some of the semantics let's say
the meanings behind a particular word uh
in in the glyphs it really helps you
know I I was just doing this uh recently
um fine-tuning some interpretations
based on uh the semantics uh of terms
spoken today right we can actually use
that information to uh get a better
sense of what they're really saying a
few hundred years earlier and presumably
these languages develop devolved
completely independently from
Indo-European precursors or East Asian
languages are there nevertheless
similarities and grammar or structure
I'm just very interested in the extent
to which there's convergent evolution
you know different language groups find
the same solutions to similar problems
well here we're getting a bit out of my
uh area of expertise but uh it is true
that mine languages and other indigenous
Lang languages of the Americas
developed on their own
the landscape of languages in the
ancient Americas is really complicated
and there are a lot of uh you know
family language families that that we
can't historically relate to one another
um you know the Aztecs spoke a language
called nawat which is a a judo Azteca
language related to some languages like
Hopi in the southwest U.S completely
unrelated to Mayan
um spoken kind of in the same general
region of mesoamerica but historically
not related right and none of these
languages really have connections to the
old world to uh Indo-European or
anything else right so it's true they
are independently tracking and and
developing and uh yes I think many
languages do come up with similar
um kind of grammatical structures and
and morphemic structures uh across the
world
um again this is an area that I'm not an
expert in that's fine yeah comparative
linguistics but uh it's a fascinating
subject
um there's a lot of deep cognitive
coding here you know this is what Noam
Chomsky uh was writing about a long time
ago uh that there's underlying uh
grammatical structures right that that
feed into uh languages uh whether
they're historically related or not well
maybe you can give us a little bit of
the sort of down to earth what it means
to decipher these languages like when
you see some symbols on a stone in uh
site in Guatemala like how do you go
about connecting these to sounds or
meanings or anything like that right so
uh the the the Deep structure of the
writing system
um we have uh really two kinds of signs
in the script we have signs that can
represent individual words
you know uh so a word like King a how in
in classic Mayan can be written with a
particular sign uh actually there are
variants of that so there may be two or
three different signs that turn out to
be the same thing that that was that was
a hard thing for us to figure out yeah
man that drove us nuts once we realized
that there were it was a very playful
script in the sense that they were
throwing at us all these kind of
variants you know trying to make us
guess but it turns out they're all the
same uh they could also write the same
word using sounds and and what they used
were consonant vowel syllables okay
um
so we have signs for sounds like
um they could combine these to really
spell anything they wanted to so
um a how King yeah you could write it
with a single sign or maybe down you
know a few lines down in a text The
Scribe will say no I'm going to write it
differently here I'm going to write it
with three signs
um
how you know when we're approaching a
new text
uh
we're always seeing things we recognize
but we always see something new we
always see a new kind of spelling or a
new new little spin on a word so there
was a built-in
flexibility a kind of an artistic
sensibility into
uh the script that I think makes it
fantastic you know to study
um one uh particular uh decipherment
that I made quite a few years ago now
was on a vessel a clay vessel that came
out of a royal tomb in Guatemala and it
had a lock top on it it had a handle on
the top you could lift it up but if you
twisted the the handle the the lid would
come off the vessel okay and it was
painted with this beautiful inscription
and one of the glyphs on it uh was I I
saw at the time it was a
combination of syllables and it read
cacao
which is a modern word okay right cacao
uh that's a word we've borrowed from
from Mayan uh Mayan borrowed it from
other Ms American languages but it's a
word that was pronounced in the ancient
times as cacao for chocolate a very
important word
it's a very important word and at the
time I told the archaeologists hey guys
this is a chocolate pot
and they uh this is great they they took
a sample of the residue that was
again miraculously preserved inside the
vessel they send it to the Hershey labs
in Pennsylvania
to have it tested and sure enough it
came back with the signatures of of
theobroma cacao
um so it was deposited in the Tomb with
with chocolate so you know that's when
we kind of knew we were on the right
track in terms of the decipherment and I
guess so I was a little bit wrong
earlier uh in in some sense it is an
alphabet right but rather than letters
as we think of it they had symbols
meaning sounds but they were not
semantic symbols right like the symbol
doesn't necess like there's not a symbol
for a leopard a single symbol for a
banana or whatever well well not
necessarily I mean there were word signs
so we have Jaguar right as a head of a
jaguar or a a drawing of a Jaguar could
be balam
for jaguar or you could write it
phonetically got it um it's not
alphabetic right alphabetic scripts are
you know a consonant and a vowel as
separate signs or con you know uh
alphabetic writing turns out to be not
that common historically
um but syllabic writing was quite common
in the ancient world Sumerians used it
for example uh in cuneiform
um and uh other ancient scripts are
syllabic as well so
um it it's as phonetically accurate as
an alphabetic script right okay good and
this helps us cycle back as it were to
the astronomy calendar kinds of
questions so you've deciphered some of
these symbols you know what they mean
and one of the things I guess at least
I'm this is from reading your book so
I'm I'm biased but they had a lot of
calendars a lot of dates lying around
and you could uh figure out what they
were talking about
yes they did and actually this was the
first wave of cracking the code way back
when in the late 1800s uh the first uh
insights into the ancient writing was
the numerology you know the numbers were
readable bars and dots
so uh very early on they they early
Scholars saw you know the bar was a
number five a DOT was a number one
combine these and you get numbers from 1
to 20. and using some of the Chronicles
that the Spanish wrote uh in the 1500s
you know they described some of the
calendars uh in those documents and and
so it it didn't take much to link these
things up
and uh
this created a situation where early
mayanists early uh epigraphers
could read
uh some inscriptions but they could only
read the dates which is weird you know
imagine looking at some sort of Roman
history and you just see see the
calendrical records and nothing else is
readable
uh
it was amazing what those early Scholars
could do uh but but they basically
hammered out the uh the the various
calendars that existed in the ancient
Maya records
uh there was a lunar calendar there was
a
solar year calendar of 365 days
there was a uh a ritual kind of
divination calendar of 260 days
not connected to any observable
phenomenon in the sky or anything like
that
or so directly and then there was this
uh uh much much larger system we call
the Long Count which is a it's based on
the
um number of 360 days right this is
almost a year okay but but Mayan
numerology is based on
20. it's a what we call a vegetable
numeration system not based on 10.
uh because
ten fingers and ten toes right against
20.
except except I gotta I gotta interrupt
because I am I I really need someone to
talk me down from this weird modified
based 20 system they use where almost
all the digits in a number are base 20
except that what there's a single digit
that it only goes up to 18. oh you had
to ask me that Sean okay it's been
bugging me right so they have a base 20
system just in their counting
independent of length of of calendars
but in the language they just have a
base 20 system of accounting so what
what happens in in this larger calendar
system we call the lung count is they
they have the number 20 and they're
going to fit that into a solar year now
they can only get to 360. right yep so
uh that creates a unit of time that's
almost a year it's not quite the year
but that becomes the building block of
this calendar system that we call the
loan count
um so 18 units of 20 days makes 360.
that it I did not catch that code and
that's where the 18 comes in uh it
always confuses my students when I'm
trying to explain the calendar is
everything is 20 except
except that one unit where you have to
make that 360 unit of time right so just
to be super clear because you know the
audience is only hearing the audio like
when we have a number like 1 382 we all
know that that's you know the one in the
thousands plays the three in the
hundreds place Etc and all of those
slots go zero one up through nine but in
the Maya way of doing it if I get it
right there's a bunch of slots and you
know the the rightmost one is the ones
and it goes from zero to nineteen and
the next one what we would call the tens
goes from zero to 17 and then all the
others go from 0 to 19 again and
this is just as crazy as it sounds but
good for them for keeping it straight
well there's a reason for that though it
sounds crazy
uh but they're not they're counting days
yeah this is only a calendrical
construct
so this is they're they're counting
individual days one through twenty makes
a period and then instead of going well
20 of that that period makes 420 of
those makes 8 000. instead of doing that
they're they're trying to Anchor it
somewhat in reality in terms of
observable solar years and so they go
you know units of 20 days they fit that
into a solar year and then they take off
and and 20 periods of 360 days makes a
period called a cartoon 20 of those
makes a baktune 20 of those
makes a pick tune and 20 of those makes
you know so this is where we get this
remarkable uh representation of deep
time
in in in some of the ritual records that
we have they're they're calculating
um
not just thousands of years but millions
billions even Beyond uh in terms of of
some of the dates they're representing
I'll give you a quick chance to explain
to us why the world did not end in the
year 2012.
[Laughter]
didn't you guys tell us it was going to
end I mean I I feel misled well it
wasn't us this is a meme that took off
uh many of us will remember going back
over a decade ago now uh that there was
this big kerfuffle right uh leading up
to December of 2012.
um there's even a movie about it right
um that the world was going to end that
the Maya predicted the end of the world
well they never said anything of the
sort
um I was tearing my hair out uh at the
time
um giving many interviews but
um you know it was impossible to oh yeah
this cultural phenomenon that was ours
right
you know I I just think our
culture civilization whatever we want to
call it sometimes we just go through
these these kind of crazy episodes of
you know whether it's Y2K or whether
it's 2012 you know there'll be something
else down the line
um the Maya never said the world would
end what happened was
that there was a turn of a period in the
Maya calendar a switch over uh called a
baktun and this is a four roughly a 400
year period of time uh it's a big deal
in the Maya calendar in the Long Count
you know I was kind of telling my
students about it like hey guys we're
going to live through the turn of a Bok
tune this is awesome
um but you know it
the interpretation of this as the end of
something was really just on us because
for the Maya it was
the beginning of something too right
um and the calendar didn't stop it kept
going this is something that I wrote my
book about at the time
um I was asked to write a popular book
about Maya time in my calendar
I don't think anyone read it but it was
it was a you know trying to explain that
no the calendar keeps going and in fact
the scale of the calendar is such that
this one period that turned over in 2012
was just a minute little Cog and a much
much bigger system so there's there's
the long count and then there's like the
super long count I don't know Long Count
uh is is is you know uses this Bok tune
period
um and you know so you you have what I
was describing earlier we have this kind
of place notation system of days of 20
days of 360 days and then 20 of those
makes a 20-year period of a cocktail 20
of those makes a bactum the 400 years
roughly now that's those five periods is
what we call the Long Count
you take a Bok tune
you can exponentially create more and
more and more and in fact they did they
just went on and you know about 19
periods on you know to gargantuan
periods of time that they're
representing that's what we call the
grand Long Count and and the they wrote
it down in its full capacity in only a
few places
um and this is what I was really
interested in seeing the the
representation of these Cycles
it's a numbers game right it's it's uh
it's just using 20 uh exponentially
um counting these periods but uh to them
it was a cosmological and numerological
statement about
um about the universe
um and one of the points I made in in
the book Sean is that their
representation of the scale of time
dwarfs our own cosmology well
I mean I would imagine that once you've
invented positional notation for numbers
it's just kind of fun to write down big
notes exactly we still have that let's
keep going and uh as you do point out in
the book which is called the order of
days still very very worth reading uh
they they were writing down numbers of
years that go into the octillions right
so for those of us who have no idea like
me what that meant uh 10 to the 28th
years is the kind of thing that they're
writing about yeah to the point where
it's almost meaningless in terms of
scale we can't wrap our heads around
that right but the the reason they're
doing this it's a good question to ask
like why bother with this yeah what
they're doing is they're
um they're taking the the BOK tune
period and they want to create
basically uh uh 20
um
orders above that here's that number 20
again
right so uh uh once they get to that
spot you know all the way up the line
then they stop
that's what I mean by saying it's a
numerological construct of time
um they're not observing anything that
that that that creates this they're
they're simply putting it down on paper
as a a fun a fascinating representation
of a structure of time so did they
attach any meanings of a beginning or an
end to the universe this way
well I suspect they did they had
creation stories
um you know uh I I think the the world
went through transformations in
mythology and in history so they
extrapolated back to create narratives
about
uh I think the creation of of the world
order as they understood it
um understanding that there were
previous uh Creations as well
um and and this is mythology right this
is this is the kind of thing we see
across the world and
um in in for the ancient Maya uh the the
narratives that we can read today uh
talk about uh 3114 BC as not a
historical date but as a important date
in the creation of kind of the present
era okay we have myths that go further
back in time hundreds of thousands
millions of years where they talk about
God's dedicating monuments and things
like that you know and and that's all
backstory for what kings are doing uh
but in 3114 BC we see kind of The
Ordering of the world the gods can all
confer together uh in in the darkness
they have kind of a big meeting
um to uh order everything in the
universe and uh we we have
um some records of this and and this is
the foundation for
um some of the other myths that we see
in in the uh dynastic records because
because Maya Kings were relating
themselves to the gods and it's also
related to to some of the stories we
have from much later on in in from
historical times uh even after the
Spanish uh Invasion so we're imagining
some
Maya in the year 500 or whatever telling
stories about what happened in the year
3000 BC I mean that seems to be not but
it wasn't 3000 BC it was
3114 or whatever it was very very
specific how did they
get there from here like how did how did
they start to the year 500 and go I know
when the current order was set it was in
the year 31 14 or whatever right so so
that 3114 BC date is kind of the base
date or the zero date for the short
version of The Long Count calendar so
um
the uh you have to think of it this it's
almost like an odometer of a car yeah
you know if you have five numbers in
front of you
um all of them set at zero that's 3114
BC August the 13th of 3114 BC in fact
now you just start clicking day you know
one day two day three and then you
accumulate these
progressively higher periods you get to
a Bach tune after 400 years well 13 Bach
Tunes
13 is a very sacred number gets you
guess where to December of 2012. okay
so uh 3114 BC and 2012 are kind of the
the the brackets you might say of of my
uh historical time or or if their sense
of kind of human time
um it keeps going
just like as it was progressively going
earlier back in time you know so uh yeah
2012 was a big deal for the for the Maya
uh it wasn't the end of the world but it
was a change I guess it's just
interesting to me because by this
process you just outlined they put
themselves in the middle of the period
which is kind of interesting it wasn't
like we're just at the beginning or
we're near the end it's a little
different than other things I've heard
yeah yeah this is interesting um I'm
glad you brought that up because uh what
I suspect is going on is that
this very uh esoteric calendar system
was probably invented
um
in in the early days of Maya
civilization not in 3114 BC the there
were there was no real Maya cities or or
you know writing going on then there
were people but there were hunting and
gathering in the area I think probably
around I don't know 700 600 BC this is
just a guess
this is the the fledgling stages of of
my uh civilization this calendar was
invented and what they wanted to do was
create a system of time a representation
of time that was scalable so that they
could go back and create narratives
about
uh history and even further back about
ancestors and and gods but also project
forward so they put themselves in the
middle I think in a very practical way
in order to represent time in both
directions it does sound like there are
structural similarities between the way
they thought about these things and and
what I anyway am more familiar with in
European history and so forth where
there were Gods uh there's I don't know
many of the societies I know about had
creation myths where you know the Earth
was vomited up by a dragon or cracked
from an egg or birthed by a Titan or
something like that I mean are there
those kind of specific fun mythological
accounts there are uh the the most
compelling narrative
um
that if people want to access some of
this
um is I mean we have plenty from the
ancient texts that we're actually still
deciphering and Publishing now you know
it's right right now we're kind of going
through this but but if if listeners are
interested in some of these narratives
um One Source that's just remarkable is
a book called The Purple which is a Maya
um epic uh poem about the creation of
the world and
of Humanity's place in it and the popovu
was
um probably not written in hieroglyphs
you know in in any of the sources that
I'm studying but rather it was written
down in
the colonial period
um in kiche Mayan this language still
spoken in in Guatemala today and it was
uh recorded by again by a Spanish uh
priest Francisco Jimenez thank goodness
he wrote this down uh in in its
indigenous language its original
language and in Spanish
so uh anyone can can there are great
translations of the popofu anything I
was going to ask you can order it and
and and and and find it and it's like
the Iliad or the Odyssey right it is
um a tremendous story about the the
world being created out of Darkness uh
about uh there's a wonderful story
within about
um a pair of brothers called the hero
twins who vanquished the Lords of the
Underworld uh and resurrect their father
um uh who turns out to be uh the god of
maize uh in in the ancient sources and
and so it's tied into you know kind of
the real world in that sense right and
and
um the the kings of the kiche Maya
um at the time of the conquest right
they were connecting themselves to these
creation stories just like you see in
the Old Testament right
um and and it's a similar kind of
impulse I think that we see that yeah
that is very fascinating just to be
helpful to the audience how do you spell
uh p-o-p-o-l
uh v u h got it and this is something
you can buy a good translation of
absolutely there's some really good
translations out there
um uh uh two or three I can think of
that that are available on you know
online and on Amazon so it's a great
story and we we can see those narratives
in some of the ancient art as well just
like you see The Iliad or the Odyssey on
Greek vases right we we see them on Maya
Pottery you know paintings and so forth
and it's fascinating to me like the
rough similarities of that kind of story
versus the Mahabharata or the Epic of
Gilgamesh or whatever completely
disconnected societies came up with very
similar stories to tell yeah yeah
exactly
um it's a human impulse you do this
right it's it's a a we all need stories
we all need narratives
um and and today science is creating
these narratives
um also right and and I I see it not
necessarily as this division between
science and mythology right because
for so many human civilizations the the
two things are are intertwined yeah
um and and that's the background of
course of our history of science
going back a ways in in the West well
let me give you an uh opportunity to
close up to you've already mentioned
that this is an exciting time to be
studying these things I mean what is on
the horizon what are we going to be
hopefully discovering or figuring out
over the next decade or two well good
question I think it is the best of times
in in our field I mean archeology is
often seen as a very literally a dusty
field right uh that maybe doesn't have a
lot of new things going on but in in our
particular Corner
um
in my archeology uh we're seeing a
transformation not only through new
technologies like lidar and Explorations
and new finds but we're seeing a
convergence of the
um kind of on the ground field
archeology
uh with a historical awareness
right that's quite new and so
um we're able now to link
um these great ruins these you know
so-called lost cities like Tikal or
Palenque or Copan you know these were
once seen as these impenetrable
um you know signs of Allah civilization
uh you know who built these ruins you
know no one ever knew you know uh a very
romanticized ideas about the Maya
developed out of that but now we know I
mean now we have the original voices of
the Maya in these places talking about
them so we have the dynasties we have
the the histories the future for me is
going to come out of this convergence of
you know the physical sights and and the
science of archeology and the history
and the the culture that we see in in
the documents and and
you know what I really want to see
happening in future Generations is an
awareness of the great actors of Maya
history the great Kings
one of the great figures of History I
think is going for the Maya is going to
be known uh widely I think I hope school
kids learn about
um some of these uh great figures and
and the things that they were doing and
even some of the
um
intellectual achievements of the Maya
and the astronomers that were doing
amazing things early on you know all of
this is coming together I think right
now and will in the next
few decades
and for people who live in the Americas
this is part of our heritage right it is
something we should know a little bit
about it is absolutely uh and especially
for the indigenous peoples of of the
area uh for the Maya who grew up often
uh at least historically in recent years
not having any awareness of this uh
Legacy
um it's it's now
really on the cusp of being uh laid out
in in all of its glory and complexity
well I'm very glad the world didn't end
I mean maybe it will a next Buck doing
away I don't know I can't predict those
things but David Stewart thanks so much
for being on the mindscape podcast thank
you Sean
[Music]
la la